merci d'être avec nous pendant cette
première demi-heure Marie-Noëlle Norman
vous êtes élu de Paris rattachés au
groupe communiste républicain citoyens
écologiste coordinatrice nationale de la
gauche républicaine et socialiste on va
bien sûr parler de la réforme des
retraites dans quelques instants mais
d'abord on l'a vu l'actualité c'est
aussi l'Ukraine volodymerzeninski qui
était donc à l'Élysée hier soir reçu par
Emmanuel Macron il va se rendre à
Bruxelles aujourd'hui avec le président
de la République son objectif obtenir
des armes et des avions au plus tôt il
faut répondre à sa demande écouter moi
ce qui me frappe c'est quand même cette
espèce de
d'escalade d'incertitude alors on nous
dit il demande d'abord des chats alors
les Américains disent non pas tout de
suite les Allemands hésitent nous on
hésite on leur après donc finalement on
donne des chats après un dire ben non
mais il faut des avions alors quels
avions lesquels non on va pas donner pas
tout de suite demain moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que normalement il y a une
coalition qui est censée être sous
l'égide de l'Otan dans ce qu'on en veut
mais c'est elle qui pilote aujourd'hui
le avec les secrets le rapport de force
pour créer un rapport de force qui
permette de libérer le territoire
ukrainien et on a l'impression qu'il y a
pas de stratégie que le les Ukrainiens
viennent demander pressé tout ça de ne
pas une impression de force ne donne pas
une impression de cohérence et ne donne
pas une sentiment d'une efficacité
suffisante pour créer le rapport de
force permettant la paix la deuxième
chose c'est-à-dire ça donne une
impression d'un oxydant parce que
pourquoi gilmo Occident l'autre chose
qui me frappe c'est qu'on a réussi à à
ce que la France soit assimilée au bloc
occidental ce historiquement dans notre
diplomatie nous essayons d'éviter
n'avons jamais été sur le concept de
bloc occidental contre les autres et qui
est à concept qui aujourd'hui nous
fragilise parce que ce qu'on ne dit pas
et qui est quand même alarmant c'est que
quand vous regardez sur l'ensemble de la
planète les alliés de du camp procréien
sont faibles finalement parce que la
défense de la démocratie était là n'est
plus devenu un motif suffisant de guerre
pour beaucoup de gens et on voit qu'à ce
moment là on ne se pose pas la question
du rapport de force internationale pour
essayer de faire que sous l'égide de
l'ONU on aboutissent un jour un accord
de paix durable parce que je vois bien
comment et ça les guerres attise
toujours les haines nous Français et
Allemand le sait bien et puis derrière
tout ça
ce jeu se joue un rôle un rapport de
force économique et dans l'armement moi
j'ai posé une question d'actualité
quand la Pologne vont donne des chats à
la à l'Ukraine souvent des vieux chats
ou des armements bon
l'Union européenne paie la Pologne pour
des nouveaux chats et deviner qu'est-ce
qui sont ces chats sont pas du tout
repérables ils sont américains et la
France on paye 18% des chars américains
achetés par les Polonais
excusé du peu et on voit comment les
États-Unis un petit peu
l'industriellement fini par se faire
financer pour avec un rapport de force
industrielle qui au final
leur effavorable et peu nous aide
défavorable donc faut faire très
attention à derrière un sentiment
évidemment généreux et une réflexion
stratégique comment on soutient un
rapport de force qui permet d'aboutir à
une paix et libérer une large partie
voir tout le territoire
ukrainien et et ces mouvements liés
quand même à des effets de communication
et un peu brownien vu de là où je suis
on parlait de la réforme des retraites
l'autre actualité les syndicats ont donc
annoncé une cinquième journée de
mobilisation ce sera jeudi prochain le
16 février la veille de la fin de
l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale quelle utilité de multiplier
ses journées de mobilisation alors qu'on
voit le gouvernement ne cède pas sur les
74 ans
à faire ce soir et attend qui pleuve
donc non c'est quelle est l'utilité de
ces mouvements d'abord on peut quand
même s'étonner qu'en démocratie
on écoute jamais le peuple et qu'après
parce que malgré tout il y a les
mouvements il y a les grèves il y a les
effets d'opinion l'unanimité des
syndicats quand même c'est quand même
rarissime et tout ça ça pèse rien du
tout devant Monsieur Macron qui a été
élu soi-disant pour ça alors qu'on l'a
élu contre Marine Le Pen donc c'est
grave pour notre démocratie mais
néanmoins c'est efficace pourquoi parce
que c'est efficace sur les députés et je
l'espère après sur les sénateurs mais il
y a quand même quand les il y a quand
même des députés qui même si eux-mêmes
dans leur fort intérieur serait plutôt
pour qu'on rallonge la durée ce disque
l'état de la société française
l'état des chiffres du corps et les
conséquences que risque d'avoir ce cette
prolongation 64 ans pose d'énormes
problèmes et qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
bien traités bien résolu même d'un point
de vue si puis dire qui n'est pas de
gauche et ces députés on voit bien que
le poids des syndicats des citoyens
leurs concitoyens même dans le dans leur
propre camp et de nature à les faire
hésiter à basculer comme un seul homme à
suivre la politique proposée par le
gouvernement donc vous pensez être en
mesure de faire réjouisser échouer ce
texte au Parlement en tout cas on peut
on peut peser pour que le rapport de
force parlementaire
s'apparente à une un nouveau alors vous
me direz il y a toujours le 49-3 mais là
au bout d'un moment ça va commencer à
faire des gros gros problèmes à notre
démocratie si on laisse faire donc moi
j'espère que samedi pour vous ça sera un
problème démocratique que le
gouvernement utilisé 49-3 sur ce thème
déjà c'est un problème démocratique non
mais c'est pas passé dans la
Constitution que ça répond aux
aspiration démocratique la démocratie
c'est pas simplement formellement suivre
des textes constitutionnels donc il y
aurait beaucoup à dire par ailleurs
c'est de permettre au peuple
de se sentir représenté entendu écouter
c'est quand même sans ça il y a pas de
démocratie durable donc bref j'espère
que samedi déjà il va y avoir de grosses
manifestations parce que ce
qu'évidemment sur quoi compte au
gouvernement c'est les difficultés
sociales des Français qui rend difficile
de faire grève pour une partie d'entre
eux mais j'espère que samedi la
manifestation sera puissante on va avoir
justement on va continuer à parler de ce
sujet on va aller du côté de Marseille
on retrouve les hauts purgate président
et directeurs éditorial de la
Marseillaise Léon on va parler avec vous
d'un sujet qui est peut-être lié avec le
financement de la réforme des retraites
ça c'est ce que nous dira manuel linman
dans quelques instants puisque vous
revenez sur les profits record annoncés
hier par le groupe Total
[Musique]
qui aujourd'hui accumule des profits
considérables donc je suis pour la
taxation c'est super profit est-ce que
c'est comme ça qu'on va financer alors
faut quand même dire pour être honnête
qu'on peut pas taxer les super profits
surtout ce que Total fait dans le monde
entier quand même chaque pays veut
prendre un petit bout de donc il faut
quand même voir que c'est pas mais quand
même c'est suffisant pour avoir des
recettes importantes ces recettes moi je
les vois plutôt utiliser pour faire
fonctionner et redresser nos services
publics le bénéficie de public en tout
cas pour que on soit en situation
d'améliorer l'hôpital l'École etc donc
mais par contre pour le financement des
retraites il me semble qu'effectivement
le débat qui se pose c'est premièrement
l'élargissement de l'assiette des
cotisants les primes toute une série de
choses parce que on essaie de détourner
le financement des
utilisation sociale qu'une part du
capital puisse intervenir et de toute
façon il y a aussi le la nécessité de
développer beaucoup plus d'emplois et de
croissance simplement il faut pas mettre
les super profits à toutes les sauces il
y a des ressources possibles pour les
retraites mais pas les super profits
parce que d'autant plus qu'après quand
tu auras moins parce que il y aura une
crise on vous dira ben non faut un truc
stable pour les retraites mais il faut
taxer les super profits et on peut
financer des retraites faut arrêter je
vais vous donner un exemple hier j'ai
posé la question sur les autoroutes
figurez-vous que un rapport de
l'Inspection des finances pas des
gauchistes dit que l'État pourrait
toucher 54 milliards si on arrêtait ces
concessions
54 milliards c'est trois années de
déficit du retraites rien qu'avec les pH
les autoroutes alors on peut baisser les
pH ou c'est pour vous dire qui a des
recettes où on gaspille de l'argent
notamment quand on a privatisé alors là
on en parle jamais d'ailleurs cette
émission boisseau alors les inspections
des finances disent l'État doit
récupérer de l'argent faut arrêter les
possessions reprendre en la gestion soit
par de nouvelles concessions ce qui
n'est pas nous thèse soit par une
relation ce que nous défendons
les autoroutes restent propriétés de
l'étape puisqu'on a fait une concession
donc la fin des concessions pose la
question d'un nouvel outil de gestion
mais à supposer même pour prendre le
raisonnement il me répond hier 50
milliards je vous ai dit c'est ce que
nous doit aujourd'hui ce que doit l'État
les concessionnaires puis après on fait
des profits parce que si eux en font
même si on en fait moins parce que les
péages sont trop chers déjà que la
moitié ce serait déjà pas mal
Léo une autre question sur les super
profils vous avez eu toutes vos réponses
la question peut-être de la
reconstitution d'un pôle public de
l'énergie pour exposer est-ce que la
sénatrice linman considère que les
activités de Total pourrait y figurer
alors ça c'est plus compliqué moi je
plaide pour un pôle public de l'énergie
au moins déjà gaz électricité ce qui
était historique parce que les activités
totales alors peut-être en oner mais sur
le pétrole c'est quand même très lié à
beaucoup d'activités internationales où
il est pas sûr que le pôle public de
l'énergie puisse intervenir notamment
sur la nécessité de forage etc donc en
tout cas il faut réguler il faut un pôle
public et une régulation publique de ce
point de vue je plaide pour des tarifs
réglementés voire même s'agissant des
sens la capacité d'encadrer les prix
alors vous allez me dire oui mais c'est
les vieilles rits tout ça bon je crois
que tout le monde a compris que le
marché de l'énergie était
européen est une aberration et qu'il
faut au mieux le transformer j'attends
de voir le temps qu'il nous faut au pire
demander en sortir au moins
momentanément tant qu'on n'a pas changé
deuxièmement j'observe qu'on polonais
en Pologne qui est quand même pas là non
plus bon il y avait plusieurs
entreprises gaz électricité ils sont
tout rachetés ils ont tout mis dans une
monopole privée mais monopole quand même
donc très honnêtement ce débat sur
sortir du marché de l'énergie européen
constitution d'un nouveau pôle public me
que je le considère comme une urgence
parce que ça pèse sur le pouvoir d'achat
ça pèse sur la compétitivité alors la
compétitivité nous parle toujours de
baisser les salaires enfin le coût du
travail et ben là oui il faut baisser le
coût de l'énergie en tout cas le rendre
stable est juste
merci au purgate merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous on regarde la Une de La
Marseillaise et l'Olympique de Marseille
évidemment la Une de La Marseillaise
olympique magnifique c'est à la Une de
votre journal après cette victoire de
l'OM sur le PSG hier soir merci beaucoup
Léo d'avoir été avec nous on va
continuer à parler de la réforme des
retraites et de la nu-pied hier devant
l'Association des Journalistes
parlementaires Olivier Faure a appris
quelques distances avec la stratégie
parlementaire de la France insoumise
dans cette réforme des retraites je ne
suis pas un insoumis je ne hurle pas
a-t-il dit il a raison
dans le débat parlementaire il y a
toujours eu des hurlements à certains
moments je crois que dans les débats
actuels ce qui se joue c'est moi je
trouve normal que on fasse de
l'obstruction Parlement quand le peuple
n'arrive pas à se faire entendre on
n'est pas là pour dire bon débattre
tranquillement gentiment techniquement
néanmoins il y a une attention
et c'est vrai que parfois nos collègues
et les filles confondent un peu meeting
et bon pas non plus exagéré
dans la vie parlementaire vous comprenez
le dépôt d'autant d'amendements oui
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contre-productif parce que vous voyez
que l'examen n'avance pas la santé il y
a même pas le mode de l'article est-ce
que si on n'arrive pas si l'assemblée
les députés n'arrivent pas à débattre de
l'article 7 qui est l'article sur le
report de Las Vegas un problème pour
vous allez vous dire il faut moduler les
choses pour au moins arriver en butée à
l'article 7 mais ce qui est fondamental
c'est quand même comment on peut quand
on est député arrivé à montrer ce
décalage entre ce que le gouvernement
essaie de faire passer avec des méthodes
pas toujours très démocratiques est-ce
qu'elle désaccord du peuple et ben jouer
la montre c'est aussi mettre le
gouvernement devant ses réalités vous
n'arrivez pas à faire voter parce que
par ailleurs le l'opinion n'est pas
d'accord il ferait de l'obstruction en
étant isolé sur des pauvres sur des
positions totalement marginales je
dirais là franchement c'est pas sérieux
mais là c'est une espèce de coïncidence
avec la mobilisation sociale mais là la
nuque doit pour vous doit retirer des
amendements pour arriver à examiner
l'article 7 avant
si on dit maintenant qu'on retire les
amendements vous voyez bien que tout ça
n'a pas de sens je pense qu'il faut
qu'on arrive situation où on n'est pas
devant l'Assemblée sérieusement des 64
ans je disais vous êtes de la gauche
républicaine et socialiste vous avez
évidemment appartenu aux parties
socialiste est-ce que pour vous la nuque
doit continuer telle qu'elle le
rassemblement de la gauche doit
continuer je pense que la Nupe a été un
accord électoral dont on voit
aujourd'hui que c'était il a été préparé
au dernier moment dans un rapport de
force particulier puisque Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avec quand même pas mal
d'effets vous utile avait obtenu et
surtout et ce sera qui est dramatique un
parti socialiste tombé à un 7 et les
autres partenaires assez faibles or
cette ce rapport de force là il était
valable à l'instant T mais il a amené
quand même qu'à 32% de total de voix au
présidentielle et 21% total de voir au
législatif donc la gauche ne peut pas se
contenter de cela faut donc trouver un
rassemblement qui permet d'élargir et
qui rééquilibre les différentes cultures
qui ont toujours existé au sein de la
gauche française donc il faut remettre à
plat la nuque avec moins de la France
choisir des scrutins vous serez en
particulier travailler sur un programme
qui pourrait être une forme de programme
commun qui n'est évidemment ne saurait
être une l'unanimisme mais qui trouve
des socles bien préparés de réformes à
la fois un peu radicale et en même temps
opérationnel qui convaincre les Français
qu'il y a une alternative sérieuse de
gauche et d'avenir on en vient à
l'actualité du Sénat pour terminer ce
sera la dernière partie on va parler
rénovation énergétique avec cette
question pourquoi la France ne parvient
pas à atteindre ses objectifs en la
matière c'est l'objet d'une commission
d'enquête à laquelle vous appartenez
marine Noël Lindman vous avez débuté vos
travaux on en parle avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour
et Audrey la commission d'enquête sur la
rénovation énergétique à l'initiative du
groupe écologiste ont commencé ses
travaux avec l'audition de deux anciens
ministres oui Ségolène Royal ministre de
l'Écologie de 2014 à 2017 et François de
Rugy ministre de la transition
écologique pendant 10 mois entre 2018 et
2019 sous le premier quinquennat Macron
ils ne sont plus aux affaires et c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils se sont permis
quelques petites piques que je vais vous
raconter je rappelle que le but de cette
mission c'est notamment de savoir
pourquoi depuis 15 ans la France ne
parvient pas à atteindre ses objectifs
en matière de rénovation énergétique et
de ce qu'on a pu comprendre dans ces
deux interventions c'est que c'est
compliqué même quand on est ministre
d'État ou même quand on est numéro 2 du
gouvernement dans le cas de Ségolène
Royal de remporter des arbitrages et
ceux même dans un contexte où on a pris
conscience depuis plusieurs années de
l'importance de réduire nos émissions à
l'époque l'ancienne ministre un crédit
d'impôt de 30% pour la réalisation de
travaux de rénovation énergétique elle
raconte comment le bras de fer a été
difficile avec Bercy vous savez dans des
arbitrages interministériels c'était des
combats d'obtenir un crédit d'impôt je
sais pas si vous rendez compte par
rapport au ministère des Finances c'est
mamie inimaginable d'obtenir un crédit
d'impôt moi comment je faisais jiminer
la COP 21 COP 21 comme 21 il faut qu'on
soit à la hauteur de la COP 21 il faut
faire des choses extra exceptionnelles
parce que c'est la COP 21 c'est comme ça
que j'arrive à arracher les arbitrages
François d'origine lui reste marqué par
un épisode la crise des fenêtres il a
tout fait pour que le double vitrage
reste subventionné
inutile de vous dire que les ministres
budgétaires on va les appeler ainsi
veulent plutôt réduire le volume et
comme vous le savez dans ces cas-là
plutôt que de le dire aussi brutalement
on dit que l'on va resserrer les
critères il avait été déjà de fait
négocier avant que j'arrive que l'on
sorte les fenêtres des subventions
possibles de crédit d'impôt au motif que
cela était le moins efficace du point de
vue de la baisse de la consommation
d'énergie ou des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et là on sans être tout
de suite dans le symbolique ou
l'efficacité de fait il y a aussi un
ressenti pour beaucoup de gens le
premier ressenti première chose auquel
il pense pour l'efficacité énergétique
c'est les fenêtres moi j'ai contribué à
dire qu'en effet c'était un peu brutal
de les sortir purement
au ministre de l'Écologie de remporter
ses arbitrages alors c'est c'est hélas
très culturel en France
de faire qu'on annonce des grands trucs
et puis alors Bercy les sphères et puis
ensuite il vous met d'énormes et limites
le champ et vous plafonnez les trucs de
telle manière qu'on dépense beaucoup
moins alors toujours avec la main sur le
cœur oui ça va c'est pas assez social
vous rendez compte il y a des gens qui
pourraient payer qui ont des aides si on
les aide pas ils feront pas et puis de
l'autre côté c'est c'est écologique donc
tout ça m'amène à une réflexion parce
que ce qui décrivait vrai je l'ai vécu
de la même manière au logement bon c'est
ça
je crois qu'il y a d'abord plusieurs
sujets sur lequel il faut que le pays
arrête on a besoin d'un certain nombre
de stabilité parce que on va pas rénover
tous les bâtiments avec des yoyos
budgétaires techniques tous les quarts
d'heure il nous faut en France au moins
pour un certain nombre de sujets sortir
de l'exigence de la dualité budgétaire
on va en parler
deuxièmement on vote des objectifs qui
sont des lois d'orientation mais on ne
vote pas des lois de programmation et
encore moins des lois de programmation
avec des outils Haddock et des
territorialisations de ces politiques
parce que si vous tenez pas compte des
réalités territoriales ce qui ne veut
pas dire que la loi doit pas être unique
mais elle doit être territorialisée dans
l'orienté dans la programmation on va en
parler de cette stabilité parce que dans
leurs auditions les ministres ont tiré
des enseignements et des idées de leur
passage au ministère de l'écologie oui
et Ségolène Royal a été extrêmement déçu
au moment de l'alternance quand son idée
de crédit d'impôt dont j'ai parlé a été
supprimé elle propose qu'en matière
d'écologie on ne puisse plus revenir sur
les avancées qui ont été obtenus
pourquoi détruire pourquoi casser ce qui
marche voyez c'est on peut réduire dans
plein de domaines pourquoi abîmer ce qui
marche ça appartient pas au ministre en
exercice appartient à la nation ça c'est
des choses sont faites et devrait y
avoir impossibilité
c'est une réflexion peut-être pour le
Sénat qui aurait pas avoir un droit de
veto en disant là vous là vous régressez
vous et le principe de non régression en
plus c'est inscrit dans la loi le
principe de non régression et je me
souviens quand Nicolas Hulot disait bah
puisque je l'appelais je lui dis mais
comment est-ce que comment est-ce que
vous avez pu laisser supprimer tout ça
je sais pas je sais pas c'est les
arbitrages sinon les arbitres non
principe de non régression vous êtes
d'accord sur ces sujets
c'est un peu entre guillemets une
pirouette c'est quoi une régression bon
c'est pour ça que je préfère inscrire
dans la loi et les objectifs et les
moyens pour quand même quand on a voté
une loi a pri
et vous voyez bien que la difficulté
quand elle dit non régressions pourquoi
le CIDE était contesté Bercy comme je
vous l'ai dit la main sur le cœur c'est
pas assez social alors vous dites comme
tout le monde y avait droit même des
gens aisés à ce moment-là il s'est passé
social il faut cibler faut donc et alors
là vous êtes d'un seul coup pour un
tiers évidemment ça coûte moins cher et
puis après on vous dit on va vous le
mettre à la nappe parce que c'est très
social et alors là il y a des plus des
pluies de dossiers à remplir pour avoir
droit au truc et Lana embouteillée même
sur lui donnait les moyens machin des
discussions sans fin sur les gens qui
croyaient avoir le machin qui l'ont pas
que le dossier n'a pas été rempli qui
met de 6 mois pour être payé bref alors
là il y a un débat stratégique est-ce
que on décide que pour la rénovation
énergétique on donne un spectre large
d'aide
un peu entre guillemets universel au
regard des des travaux faits et on
réfléchit à des fiscalités qui
nourrissent ces crédits et qui elle soit
juste moi par exemple je plaise que pour
tous les logements dépassant 10000 euros
du mètre carré il y a une petite
cotisation de solidarité logement ça
pourrait être pour la rénovation
énergétique vous voyez et ça
Bercy ne veut pas préfère des critères
restrictifs inopérants qui nous
permettent pas d'atteindre les objectifs
oui François de Rugy a parlé aussi de
l'acceptabilité et c'est vrai qu'on a
des objectifs ambitieux la neutralité
carbone à horizon 2050 ça paraît loin
mais c'est demain comment on fait
justement pour rendre les choses
acceptables pour les Français il faut
faire les arbitrages qui
quitte entraîne les gens et d'ailleurs
François de Rugy lui dit assez justement
faut une part d'obligation temps
résorption n'est pas sur thermique on
peut plus les louer un horizon
raisonnable pour que les gens puissent
faire les travaux et de l'autre côté des
incitations pour ceux qui ont besoin ou
de manière un peu plus générale donc ça
l'acceptabilité ça me paraît très très
important dans la période et je vais
vous dire parce que on parle des
logements mais moi je trouve que on est
hyper faible sur l'investissement pour
les bâtiments publics si déjà tous les
bâtiments publics on avait un plan par
exemple commençons avec des objectifs
simples et lisibles tous les bâtiments
scolaires on se donnait 5 10 ans je sais
rien pour qu'il soit tous à des très
bonnes normes énergétiques d'abord c'est
une culture pour nos enfants qui voient
que deuxièmement ça donne une lisibilité
à la filière bâtiment
troisièmement ça permet aussi
d'accompagner des améliorations en
termes d'innovation technologique ce qui
est nécessaire
parce que on va permettre que des trucs
qui rendent les ou des choses qui sont
compliquées donc tout ça pour vous dire
qu'en effet
il faut que ce soit acceptable et
entraînant
merci excusez-moi mon dérapage vous en
prie on vous en prie merci beaucoup
madame merci Audrey on se retrouve tout
à l'heure on va parler
très peut-être trop nombreux enfants on
verra un gros sujet à gros sujet pour
eux pour notre sujet justement on verra
ça ce sera dans le club et puis dans ce
club on viendra également sur la
mobilisation des agriculteurs c'était
hier des centaines de tracteurs qui ont
convergé vers Paris leur motifs de
protestation notamment l'interdiction
des néonicotinoïdes pour les producteurs
de betteraves on verra tout ça merci
beaucoup marine Noéline d'avoir une
connerie merci à vous on passe tout de
suite on accueille notre prochaine
invitée